Over the past several years, many of us have
learned how incredibly life-threatening and
dangerous viruses and diseases can be.
They can cause any number of critical symptoms
and can shut down your body’s processes
in a wide variety of ways.
But there are more diseases than just the
ones we can name off the top of our heads
based on our recent experience.
Many of these have nothing anomalous about
them, despite being incredibly strange.
Take progeria: it’s a genetic condition
that causes people carrying a very specific
gene mutation to age rapidly.
Not twice as fast, either - so fast that most
victims tragically don’t live past their
early teens.
Or elephantiasis.
If you’re thinking that’s a disease affecting
elephants, you’d be wrong, but not grossly
so.
It causes the lymph nodes in your body to
stop draining fluid correctly, so it pools
up and makes your body parts swell to a massive
size - until you look like an elephant.
And of course, there’s the nasty disease
known more commonly as the bone-growth disease,
or the bone-prison syndrome.
When most people’s muscle cells die, they
get a nasty bruise but no lasting damage.
But for people with this rare genetic mutation,
dead muscle cells ossify - they turn into
bone.
And muscle cells die slowly anyway, even if
they’re not damaged in any way.
Over the years, sufferers have their body
gradually turn into solid bone.
All strange and terrifying, aren’t they?
But none of them are anomalies, surprising
as it may seem.
They’re all perfectly real diseases, documented
by modern science - you can even search them
up and see evidence, if you don’t believe
us.
But it begs the question: if these seemingly
logic-defying and impossible diseases are
just the ones known by modern science, then
what kind of diseases break our understanding
of science, physics, biology, and chemistry
so much that they need to be categorized as
anomalous?
And, of course, contained by the Foundation.
We have a few examples: the most notable of
which is SCP-008, the fabled “Zombie Plague”.
Exactly what it sounds like on the tin.
But today we’re going to be looking at something
else entirely: one of the many “anomalous
biohazards” that the Foundation keeps in
cold-storage deep below the surface of the
Earth to ensure that they never infect another
human being again.
But this one is a little unique - when we
talk about dangerous diseases, we always consider
the outcome, the most danger a disease could
possibly pose, to be death.
However, our topic for the day doesn’t do
that.
Frankly, death might be preferable to what
it does to you.
SCP-2376 has a nickname around the Foundation’s
medical department.
They call it “the Scarecrow Virus”.
That name alone raises a lot of questions
- usually diseases are named scientifically,
or according to the symptoms they give to
anyone unlucky enough to be infected by them.
But scarecrows aren’t dangerous - they’re
not even alive.
The simple little straw effigies that farmers
stick in their corn and wheat fields so that
crows don’t pick their crops clean before
they can even be harvested.
What do scarecrows have to do with a biological
threat that the Foundation has decided is
dangerous and anomalous enough that it must
be contained, lest the wider world learn about
it?
Well, I suppose the only way to find out is
by reading its documentation.
Which is, honestly, quite sparse.
It’s not the massive multi-page goliaths
that many entries can turn into - it’s short,
it’s simple, and perhaps it's better that
way.
This is one of those cases where the more
details you get, the more disturbing the anomaly
is.
But let’s get into it.
SCP-2376’s object class is euclid.
Which is, at least, a good first sign.
It means that it’s not too hard to contain,
which in the context of a disease means that
it’s not amazingly communicative or contagious.
That’s good, all things considered - SCP-008
and SCP-610, by contrast, are incredibly communicative
and that’s part of why they can be so hard
for the Foundation to contain.
The Special Containment Procedures for SCP-2376
are a little odd - in fact, they barely reference
SCP-2376 itself.
Instead, they mostly refer to SCP-2376-1 instances.
And how to care for them, feed them, communicate
with them, and so on and so forth.
They go into detail that SCP-2376-1 instances
can’t be fed normally, but by using an automated
feeding system to limit human exposure to
them.
But they still need meticulous care - they
have to be examined at least once every 8
hours by Foundation medical staff - and the
discomfort that comes as a result of their
infections is to be alleviated as much as
possible.
While precise, they’re not exactly surprising.
We know it’s a disease, so it makes sense
that these SCP-2376-1 instances are the victims
of the disease - and as they’re severely
ill, they need to be fed and examined without
making their condition, whatever it is, even
worse or spreading it to staff.
But they go on, and they get stranger.
SCP-2376-1 instances can’t actually be informed
or made aware of the fact that the disease
they’re suffering from, SCP-2376, is anomalous
for some reason.
They can’t be told about the anomalous properties
of it.
A text-based communicator for the disabled,
kind of like the computer-voice system used
by Stephen Hawking, has to be used to communicate
with the instances, but personnel can’t
just wait for them to type something out.
They have to close and reopen their eyes every
5 minutes to see if they’ve typed anything
out.
For some reason, either victims of SCP-2376
can’t move when they’re being looked at,
like the infamous SCP-173, or that people
can’t sense that victims have moved until
they close and reopen their eyes.
Either way, very anomalous, not to mention
the fact that they won’t or can’t speak.
The next line is a very hard, very firm rule,
though, not just a directive for care: “Under
absolutely no circumstances are patients to
be removed from their rooms or disposed of”.
No removing from rooms makes sense - you don’t
want the disease to spread and cross-contaminate
with the various other anomalies that a Foundation
site has in its halls.
Who knows what kind of superbug you might
wind up with?
But ‘disposal’ is a different matter - the
Foundation isn’t allowed to get rid of victims
of this disease.
That seems obvious - the Foundation doesn’t
kill people if at all avoidable.
Clearly, something else is at play here.
The next line gives a hint: personnel have
to follow any instructions given to them while
treating instances, and have to be regularly
reminded that they’re treating a human being.
Whatever this disease does to people, it causes
others to not recognize them as human and
may accidentally dispose of them.
All the instances/victims, as well as samples
of the disease itself, are located at Site-234
and MTF Beta-7, the “Maz Hatters”
are to regularly investigate hospitals in
areas with prior infection for repeat instances.
Beta-7 is a Mobile Task Force trained and
equipped specifically to deal with contagious
or infectious anomalies, a cross between soldiers
and doctors.
SCP-2376 is a substrain of the real-world
tetanus virus, which is often called lockjaw.
Most people get a tetanus shot in childhood
that protects them from the disease, with
regular booster shots, so they never have
to suffer through the grisly infection that’s
often found on rusty metal.
Lockjaw is called that because the bacteria
infects your muscles and makes them violently
spasm, locking your jaw muscles into a closed
position.
There’s no cure, and about ten percent of
cases are fatal.
But the Scarecrow Virus is different.
While tetanus is found on rusty nails, SCP-2376
is zoonotic; it’s communicated and carried
by animals, specifically the common crow.
That sheds some light on the name.
While it’s carried by crows, it’s transmissible
to humans too.
As we guessed, the unfortunate victims are
designated SCP-2376-1 instances by the Foundation.
SCP-2376’s infection of humans consists
of two distinct stages, Stage 1 and Stage
2.
Stage 1 is, of course, first, and at first
seems mild.
It lasts between one and four weeks and has
all the symptoms of the regular tetanus virus,
like a fever, spasms, and loss of mobility,
but with some extra ones - people also develop
a reddish rash across their body, a cough,
and vertigo; they become afraid of heights.
That would be strange enough, but it also
affects the senses.
Victims who haven’t progressed to Stage
2 yet complain about always smelling the odor
of straw, corn, and other materials you’d
find on a farm, even when they’re nowhere
near any farm.
They say that everything they touch has a
strange sort of film or texture on it, like
rough burlap - the kind you’d find a bag
of potatoes to be made of.
This is all certainly strange, but it’s
not something that you’d think MUST be contained
by the Foundation.
Just an odd variant of the tetanus virus.
But Stage 2 is where things really get complicated.
The anomalous properties of the disease become
readily apparent after the victim progresses
to Stage 2.
They stop being perceived as human - anyone
who looks at them only sees a regular, unmoving,
inanimate scarecrow.
It’s not that they become a scarecrow, either.
Just that people can no longer perceive them
as anything but - which is arguably worse.
Observers don’t realize that the person
they were looking at just a moment ago is
suddenly gone or has been replaced by a scarecrow
- to them, everything seems normal.
They don’t realize or question that anything’s
wrong.
In fact, they can’t even perceive any noises
a SCP-2376-1 instance makes, like yelling
or calling for help.
That’s why they have to use the text communicators.
But why the five minute delay?
Because people can’t perceive any motion
by SCP-2376-1 instances either, at least not
while looking at them.
If one runs across the room right in front
of an observer, they won’t realize it, and
will see the scarecrow still sitting where
it started.
But, if they look away by turning around or
closing their eyes before making visual contact
with it again, the scarecrow will be in the
position where the SCP-2376-1 instance stopped
moving.
The disease doesn’t just affect the person
who has it - once Stage 2 sets in, it affects
people who don’t have it and have no exposure
to it, besides looking at a victim.
That’s why it’s anomalous - it manages
to change how people’s nervous systems and
senses act while never even infecting them.
SCP-2376 can’t infect microphones or motion
detectors either, though.
Any sounds made will still be picked up in
a sound recording, and anyone tripping a motion
detector alarm will have it sound immediately.
That makes containment a little easier, now
that the Foundation can depend on at least
physics and sound.
But then you’d think a picture or photograph
of an SCP-2376-1 instance would look like
a normal person, right?
Albeit bedridden with a rash and spasming,
but a human being.
You’d be wrong, and same about videos.
Visual media just renders victims as what
they appear to the naked eye: a regular, harmless
scarecrow.
There is one way to stop the effect that SCP-2376
has on perceiving its victims - but it’s
not pretty.
When a victim dies of the infection, they
can be perceived as a human again, though
of course by then it’s far too late.
Thankfully, being infected by SCP-2376 isn’t
a death sentence.
The parts and symptoms of the disease that
are shared with regular tetanus can be alleviated
with the same treatments and remedies - though
they can’t be fully cured.
And even if all the other symptoms go away,
the largest and most anomalous aspect, the
effect on others perceptions, stays.
As of testing so far, there’s no way to
get rid of that aspect of the disease - except,
of course, death.
And the Foundation has performed extensive
testing with samples of SCP-2376.
Murine models - they infected lab rats with
the disease to see if the reaction was the
same as humans and how it compared to lab
rats with tetanus.
The answer was extremely similar: just like
tetanus, if a SCP-2376-1 instance was pregnant
when they were infected, the disease would
easily transfer to the fetus and give the
baby the Scarecrow Virus from birth.
And rats that went to Stage 2 also were perceived
as scarecrows - tiny little straw-stuffed
scarecrows shaped like mice and stuffed with
denim and straw.
But unlike humans, rats and mice eat straw.
Which is exactly what the non-infected rats
began to do to the infected ones.
They were unable to perceive the rat’s cries
or thrashing, and cannibalized it - but SCP-2376
and tetanus are bacterial infections.
By eating the infected rats, the other rats
also became infected, showing the disturbed
Foundation researchers how this disease managed
to spread unnoticed.
Protocols were immediately implemented to
make sure rats and mice couldn’t get into
the containment chambers of SCP-2376-1 instances,
lest they try to start eating them and spread
the disease like wildfire through Site-234.
Until the medical researchers can get a better
understanding of what exactly SCP-2376 is
and how it affects other animals besides crows,
people, and mice, testing is ordered to continue
and several other researchers have noted how
similar the effects of the virus are to other
anomalies, such as SCP-2316, a pathogen that
causes the entire body to lock up and stop
doing everything, and SCP-2218, a number of
teleporting intelligent scarecrows.
Maybe SCP-2376 is the result of these two
anomalies coming into contact and interacting,
as some of the researchers are investigating?
Or maybe it’s much more nefarious - perhaps
these three anomalies share a common, synthetic
origin, like someone trying to create an anomalous
biological weapon.
Or maybe it really just is a coincidence.
SCP-2376 was first encountered by the Foundation
in the exact place anyone would expect to
find straw and scarecrows: the wide, vast
cornfields of Iowa in the United States.
But they didn’t find them in a field of
wheat or in a barn: they found them where
you’d expect to find disease victims - a
hospital.
More specifically, Foundation agents found
a number of corpses stuffed into the garbage
disposal units of the hospital of a small
Iowa town.
The nurses and janitors at the hospital had
no idea what happened - they said that some
teenagers had broken in during the night and
dressed a number of scarecrows in scrubs before
leaving them in the wards as a prank.
The staff in the morning had found and disposed
of them in the trash.
Knowing what we know about SCP-2376, the actual
story is much more tragic.
Somehow, the infection had probably gotten
into a human at the hospital, and the doctors
began treating it the same as they would tetanus.
The doctors and nurses had also gotten infected,
and quickly entered into Stage 2 while at
work.
But remember - victims stop being perceived
as scarecrows when they die, which means that
when the hospital staff threw them into the
trash, they were still alive - if you can
call that alive.
But their thrashing and yelling couldn’t
be perceived by the others.
Once they went into the disposal units, they
quickly deteriorated and died.
A deeply tragic situation all around.
But how did SCP-2376 get to the hospital?
Where did it even come from?
Foundation agents have a pretty solid theory.
They scoured the local town for any strange
events, incidents, or rumors about scarecrows,
and found something much bigger than what
they were expecting.
A week before the corpses in the hospital
were discovered, a man in the next town over
had died.
Or more accurately - he had been killed.
His wife called 911 incoherent and sobbing,
and explained to the operator that she had
found a spare scarecrow in the garage a week
before, and had nailed it up outside of the
house on a post.
After three days, she had walked outside and
found, instead of the scarecrow, the body
of her husband, at which point she broke down
and called 911.
The woman was tried for murder but acquitted
on an insanity plea, based on her claims of
her husband having turned into a scarecrow.
The man’s corpse was sent to the morgue
at the hospital for an autopsy, which is probably
how the infection spread to other hospital
staff.
But not before the autopsy was completed and
a report filed indicating cause of death:
dehydration from being out in the hot sun
for three days.
Foundation staff quickly moved in and quarantined
the body, confirmed the presence of SCP-2376
in the blood and the wife confirmed her husband
had symptoms similar to tetanus a few weeks
ago.
As for how the infection got into the man,
that remains a mystery.
The outbreak was considered contained by the
Foundation, and since then there have been
only cases here and there throughout the American
midwest.
Until now - an addendum to the file indicates
that the Foundation has located and identified
a new strain of SCP-2376, the key difference
being the carrier and the effect.
Rather than crows, it is transmitted by pigeons
- and its origin point is in a highly urban
location in Illinois.
More likely than not, it’s in the third
largest city in the United States - Chicago.
And the second difference is that instead
of scarecrows, the infected are perceived
as inanimate mannequins, the kind you’d
see in any clothing or department store.
Based off the vastly increased risk for an
epidemic, the Foundation’s medical department
have requested that SCP-2376 be reclassified
to Keter.
SCP-2376 goes to show how even the diseases
we don’t know exist can be dangerous in
more ways than just threatening our lives.
So next time you see a crow scavenging for
food in your front lawn, maybe think twice
about getting too close to scare it away.
You might just wind up on a pole in that same
front yard scaring crows away in your new
straw-stuffed overalls forever.
Now go check out “SCP-1025 - Encyclopedia
of Common Diseases” and “SCP-610 - The
Flesh That Hates” for more on anomalous
diseases that will leave you crawling in your
skin!